hello my friends on the Internet it's me
Bandit I hope you've all been having a
great summer actually it is not summer
anymore it's very much so not summer
anymore it's literally Halloween day
while I'm recording this so I have no
idea why I said summer so let me do that
again I hope you've all been having a
great
fall and I hope that you've been playing
a lot of video games and having a lot of
fun playing said video games I um am
sure you've noticed that things on the
channel have been a little different
recently and by different I mean
nothing's been happening ever since
tears of the Kingdom released my uploads
kind of went that's like a car like just
hit the brakes you know like it's just
kind of stopped or slowed down
exponentially and there are a couple of
reasons for that and I just kind of
wanted to level with you all say hello
show my face let you all know that I'm
still alive barely I'm sure you can tell
I've got the sniffles cuz it's been
dipping in the temperature outside but
you know besides my red nose and
terrible appearance um I just wanted you
to know that I am alive and otherwise
healthy and I hope the same for all of
you but there are some things that I
need to level with you about and I think
it's only fair to level with you about
these things because it's going to be
affecting the content on the channel
going forward because yes the channel is
going forward contrary to what some of
you no doubt were thinking uh but it's
going to be it's it's going to be a
little bit of a little bit of change so
first things first I'm just going to
come out and say it although before I
say it I do want to preface everything
that I say about whatever games I talk
about in this video I want to specify
and reiterate iterate and reiterate that
anything that I say in this video is
just my opinion and you would do well to
remember that uh and you would do well
to remember that everybody has opinions
and some opinions are stinkier than
others sure but that doesn't make them
any less of a valid opinion right unless
of course you're of the opinion that
like 2 + 2 equal
3 but that's not an opinion that's just
a that's just factually wrong anyway you
get what I'm saying if I say something
in this video about games tears of the
Kingdom about games that you don't agree
with just let it be all right it's my
opinion is what it is it's going to hit
everybody differently so here we
go when tears of the Kingdom released I
think that a lot of the people in the
Zelda fandom were excited obviously for
a couple different reasons one it was a
brand new Zelda game coming out well I
say brand new right but of course it was
still in the same world as as breath of
the wild was set in but it was a brand
new experience from the ground
up with an asterisk beside that because
again it was the same link and controls
and world as breath of the wild but
anyway you know what I mean you get what
I'm saying it was an it was a very
exciting new
experience and one of the other reasons
why people were so excited for people
like myself and people like undoubtedly
you watching this video and you who
watch my channel uh it was exciting
because of the lore possibilities that
came with the game cuz see breath of the
wild was in
a breath of the wild was vague right I
think that's kind of an understatement
breath of the Wild's entire world has
references to like all of the other
Zelda games out there there there's no
shortage I mean you you can liter find
the ruins of lawn laon Ranch you know
from ocarine of time and you can find an
entire like intact mostly intact uh uh
Shrine of whatever it's called from
Skyward Sword I'm sorry I I haven't been
researching recently my terminology is
kind of gone right now uh listen if you
don't if you don't keep studying
something sometimes you lose some terms
all right but you know what I'm talking
about breath of the wild introduced new
lore to the
series but in a way that was still
Loosely connected to everything and it
was very interesting and it worked for
breath of the wild and it gave rise to
Zelda theories like we had never seen
them before because people have always
theorized about the Legend of Zelda hell
that's why Nintendo went ahead and made
the timeline Canon back in you know the
2000s because the fans of the Zelda
franchise love to theorize and connect
pieces between games and whatnot and you
know what it's fun because we fans of
the series like that sort of thing you
know not all fans do but a lot of fans
do all right and when breath of the wild
came out it
was it was strangely new but also the
same but there were certain things that
were just missing but because breath of
the wild was the only game in this new
lore Continuum if you will it worked we
could talk about where's the Triforce we
could talk about where's Ganondorf we
could talk about you know things like
that because it was just breath of the
wild and theories were very very fun and
because of that we knew that when breath
of the wild was getting a sequel a
direct sequel oh boy that must mean all
sorts of stuff for the theories and the
lore of breath of the wild we were
finally going to get answers about a lot
of the the things that I just mentioned
you know Ganondorf the Triforce and
speaking of Ganondorf they announced
before tears of the Kingdom even came
out that he was going to be the main
villain so there were so so many reasons
to be excited for tears of the kingdom
and the story that it was going to bring
to us now I'm not going to go into all
of it because well one I don't want to
piss everybody off uh
because you're Pro you were probably
expecting me to absolutely love tears of
the kingdom and I think I think if you
were to ask me that question the answer
is not very it's not very simple it's
complicated do I like tears of the
kingdom yes I think it's fantastic
experience I think that the best way you
could experience tears of the Kingdom
from a gameplay perspective would be to
experience it without having played
breath of the wild beforehand because
90% of the game is still just walking
around the same world of Hyrule there
should have been so many more sky
islands they should have done so much
more with the depths but again I'm not
doing a fullon like review video where I
just bash the things that I don't like
about tears of the Kingdom uh because
there was plenty to like uh the crafting
system obviously and I'm talking about
The zonai Crafting system crafting your
gizmos and gadgets and flying machines
and weapons and whatever and the fuse
system was really cool um but gameplay
aside did I like tears of the
Kingdom honestly no and and and to and a
lot of that is on me because as not just
a fan of the series but as a
Creator specifically a Zelda
theorist um i w i I talked about all
sorts of wh if scenarios uh for tears of
the kingdom and the thing is it's fun to
talk about those sorts of things but you
got to be careful right because you got
to be able to temper your
expectations and so to me man the things
that I focused on and was expecting to
hear about one of the the one of the
biggest things of which was like the
Triforce was just was it wasn't even
hinted at tears of the Kingdom like it
it was just and there are a lot more uh
topics than just the Triforce but I'm
just using that as an example of how the
lore and and story of Tears of the
Kingdom just did not care at all about
anything that I wanted it to care about
instead it spent the time uh building up
again new lore like the birth of hyru
was birthed by the Zoni type new lore
and this is just another Ganondorf and
another imprisoning war and another set
of sages and another all powerful set of
relics called the zonai stones or the
zonai secret stones and and the master
sword can now break because of the
superpower that Ganondorf has from one
of these new relics and then the master
sword needs one of these new relics to
repair itself to be able to beat this
other New Relic and where what where's
the Triforce again you know what what
Triforce what golden goddesses what what
what are you talking about uh who cares
about that it's all about the zonai
you see what I mean like there was there
was nothing in tears of the Kingdom that
I wanted there to be and there was
everything that I didn't really care
about and uh it's almost like Nintendo
was watching
YouTube like developing tears of the
kingdom and they watched our videos and
Nintendo black crisis's videos and
zeltic videos and monster Ma's videos
and hro Gamers and like everybody's
videos about the Zoni excuse me and they
were like you know what that's good
that's really good why don't we just do
everything in the sequel about them and
like anything that could possibly be a
question of anything just it was the
zonai the whole time does it have to
connect anything in the series no it can
just be completely new okay see see now
I'm ranting and I don't want to rant
about Tu of the Kingdom because like I
said I don't want to tick anybody off
but I just I need to let you know how I
feel about the game so that I can tell
you what's going to happen to the
channel because of
this now where the hell was I oh yeah
and then like randomly the director of
breath of the wild and tears of the
Kingdom fuju Bashi comes out in an
interview and says oh it could you know
the birth of hyru could have been a new
Continuum or not a new Continuum but
another like hyru could have been
destroyed again in the past and then
like it was built again in the past and
like the passage of tens of thousands of
years doesn't matter and hundreds of
like here's the thing okay here's the
thing about tears of the Kingdom Lord
and what it proved about the era of the
wild of Zelda game so breath of the wild
and tears of the kingdom and I guess age
of Calamity but it's not canon so who
cares uh but what it proved about them
and also a little bit about the rest of
the series is
that the lore of the series doesn't
really matter it really needs to just
be I hesitate to say this because it's
not
true but it kind of is but it's almost
like the lore of Zelda games needed just
be handled game to
game I mean and I say that's not true
because Zelda games reference other
Zelda games within the Zelda games but
when every game comes out and especially
the previous two and
just doesn't care about any of the
previous Zelda games and just introduces
new
stuff and to be honest with you it's not
altogether all that interesting anymore
that entire that very concept right
there affects people like me people who
who try to generate interesting topics
and theories to talk about see I haven't
been just sitting on my ass this entire
time since tears of the Kingdom came out
and not well I have been but what I mean
is I haven't been theoretically sitting
on my ass and not coming up with video
ideas I have video ideas this isn't a
video that's that's crying to people to
give me video ideas I there are so many
it's it's an it's an entire world okay
there are so many things to talk about
in tears of the Kingdom what's this
person's story what's that person's
story you know whatever and we could
explain lore all day long but here's the
thing it's not that interesting anymore
it worked in breath of the wild because
things were just vague enough and it was
just breath of the wild so we could
still kind of Wiggle around and make
things connect and talk about what ifs
but now that tears of the Kingdom has
come out and it's like we still don't
know what the hell the dragons are we
still don't like we we still don't know
where the golden goddesses are we still
don't know if this is the same high we
don't even know if this is the same
Hyrule that has been traversed in the
rest of the series or if it's like the
new Hyrule from the adult timeline or
like and we don't know what the hell
happened to the Triforce is it within
Zelda it how how is it within Zelda I
mean clearly we're just writing new
rules for stuff in tears of the Kingdom
like there's there's just zonai secret
Stones now and they can bust things up
like The Master Sword and the master
sword used to be more powerful than the
Triforce by the way cuz Ganondorf the
Triforce of power Infuse him literally
return him from the dead in in Twilight
Princess and the master sword was the
only thing that could actually
permanently kill a Triforce empowered
individual like the master sword is all
powerful Darkness cannot even be near
the blade and then like a new little
teardrop Stone empowers a dude gives him
Gloom and Gloom just snaps the freaking
sword like it's a little toothpick you
know so like we're clearly we're just
writing new mythology for the Legend of
Zelda that overrides everything that
we've known so far and to me because
you've got to remember I'm a fan first
before I'm a Creator the the only reason
why I was a Creator about the Legend of
Zelda specifically and to the extent
that I have been on my channel is
because it's been my favorite franchise
and why is it my favorite franchise
because it's the most interesting it's
always been the most interesting to me
it's the most heartfelt it's got the
music it's got the the the stories it's
got the lore and it's got the themes
that the same across the games and it's
always just been so cool to me I
remember when I was a kid you know the
first time that I played Wind Waker and
the intro segment like described the
events of ocarine of time I was a kid
and I saw that and that was amazing to
me I was like wow it's like a Contin and
that was the same Ganondorf and then it
was so much deeper now and like you
needed multiple games to kind of
understand his entire
story that is cool to me and again
that's not cool to everybody but it's
cool to people like me it's interesting
to people like
me and that's my problem with tears of
the kingdom and honestly with breath of
the wild too but more so tears of the
Kingdom it's like none of that stuff
matters anymore a new Zelda game can
come out and it can just write new rules
like
in in in the next game who knows it
might just be
like there might not even be a spirit of
the hero anymore or or you know you know
what I mean do you understand what I'm
saying I don't even know if I'm coming
across intellect actually at this point
I just kind of turned turned the camera
on I didn't really know what this video
was going to be and I'm just talking I'm
just talking about how I feel about
tears of the kingdom and I didn't even
it's it's been my camera's been rolling
I probably cut this video down by the
time you're watching it but my camera's
been rolling for well over 15 minutes
and I did not mean to make this video
that long so I'm going to stop there but
just to summarize I don't know if I said
it or not but just to summarize what I'm
trying to
say tears of the king kingom story is
not that interesting to
me there I said it so what is that going
to do to the channel that is the reason
why I'm making this video it's going
to basically I'm not I'm I'm really not
going to do videos on tears of the
Kingdom anymore and it's I think that's
a big disappointment for me because you
know for years ever since tears of the
kingdom was uh uh teased back in 2019 as
breath of the wild 2 you know the sequel
to breath of the Wild I mean like
everybody and their mom was looking
forward to that right and and we were
all looking forward to it for many
reasons many purposes like I was looking
forward to having years worth of content
to talk about uh because of Tears of the
kingdom and then it released and I was
just like wow nothing really matters
anymore and then they went and said that
there will be no DLC additions for tears
of the kingdom and that was like the
nail in the coffin to me
so I I covered the game with my boss
lore video Z because I yeah I did
another one that was just focused on
Ganondorf um in tear of the kingdom and
I think I think that's about it I don't
know if I'm going to do my dungeon lore
video for tears of the Kingdom because
again none of it really
matters it's all just new stuff I mean
there was so much in tears of the
Kingdom that they could have capitalized
on
could you
imagine if the lightning dungeon or
whatever the hell it's called the one in
the gudo desert could you imagine if
that was the resurrected arbiter's
grounds I mean that's what everybody was
expecting but no you know it had to be
some new some new ancient zonai ruins
thing Everything is zonai Everything is
zonai and man there were there were
certain things in tears of the Kingdom
again I I don't know what reminded me of
this I think my brain was just going
through the dungeon and I remembered the
cut scenes at the end of The Dungeons
and so now I just I just got to mention
it tears of the
Kingdom like how could Nintendo release
a product that has like those copy and
paste cinematics in it you know what I'm
talking about whenever you finish a
dungeon and your helper you know be it
Ru or taba Tia's kid I forget what his
name is or or yibo or or whoever you
know or seiden
it when you finish the dungeon you are
met with like the spirit of the ancient
sage and they say the same damn thing
that every other one says and your
partner character says the same damn
thing Demon King secret Stone secret
Stone Demon King Demon King secret Stone
and the and it's it's the same it's the
same copy and paste cinematic like
there's no character development there's
no anyway anyway I got to stop
I got to stop see cuz I'm not I'm not
trying to make this one of those videos
I'm just doing this so that I can
explain to you what's happening anyway
I've been rambling for long enough so
like I said I'm really not going to be
making videos based on tears of the
Kingdom anymore does this mean I'm going
to be not covering the Zelda franchise
uh no not at all of course I'm going to
cover the Zelda franchise I mean like
it's the Zelda franch this was not
enough to shake the Zelda franchise from
being my favorite
franchise although it comes close
because there are other really really
goodan franchises that I enjoy which
leads me to my next point because I'm
not going to be drawing from tears of
the Kingdom really I mean it may come up
in videos obviously because it is a
Zelda game but because I'm not going to
be drawing from it for like my main
source of videos I'm I know I've talked
about it for years now at this point but
I like it's time to Branch out for the
channel like it's it's officially it is
time so if there is one thing that I
would ask from you guys if you're still
watching this hi to those of you who are
still watching this if you if you're
still watching this just comment hello I
am still watching this down
below you know just do that but anyway
if you're still watching this after you
leave that comment either edit that
comment or put another comment um about
what your favorite franchise is besides
the Legend of Zelda not even a video
idea I just want to know like what you
guys's favorite franchises are um I
could talk about what mine are but that
doesn't really matter uh but yeah just
let me
know and yeah that's about it that's
about all I had to say oh before I let
you guys go since you're all still
watching clearly and you've all just
left those comments saying hello I'm
still watching this um you should go to
a link to success excuse me a linkto
success.com why because that's my book
yeah in the in the meantime I've been
helping um Athena hotus which is a
phenomenal
entrepreneur uh friend of mine that I
was blessed to have met via her reaching
out to me in email um but I've been
helping uh her a little bit with some
contributions uh in a book that she has
written she's the author but I'm I wrote
the forward and several parts of each of
the chapters um things like that anyway
it's called a link to success it is a
Zelda book but it's a book about finding
success out of our love for the Zelda
franchise so I greatly I highly
recommend you heading over to the
website and just checking it out and if
you do decide to pre-order it um I
believe we are going to be meeting up
and signing uh the pre-ordered copies
physical copies of course it is also up
for digital but you know I can't really
sign a digital copy but if you want a
signed copy of that book from the author
and
myself hop on that pre-order but anyway
that's about all I had I just just
wanted to bring you guys up to speed
with where I was because you know things
on the channel have been very quiet um
and I wanted to temper your expectations
for what is to come which is like I said
videos about the Legacy Zelda games you
know I still have the dungeon lore and
the boss lore videos to complete for the
other games in the series um but I'm
also going to be branching out that that
video series to other franchises and
just covering other franchises in
general all right sound good team will
you guys have a very happy Halloween I
hope it's spooky make sure Mike Myers
doesn't gut you in an Alleyway and yeah
that's about the size of it I'll see you
guys
later if any of you are in
Texas I'm doing a show in Granbury
Granbury opera
house um we got two more weekends it's
called Agatha Christies and then there
were none I'm literally like the camera
is still rolling and I'm just telling
you guys about this I don't even know
why anyway if you want to come see me in
the show I'm still doing that for the
next two weekends at the Granbury opera
house okay eat lots of
candy peace